well I Darwin Darwin ah da Gillette Nagi
- was it
first comes the strong hot coffee and
then the sweet tea those gathered here
belonged to the Bani Assad or sons of
lion tribe it's early in the morning
members of the group come here to
exchange news and settle disputes
they're meeting in a motif in southern
Iraq the reed houses are an
architectural masterpiece a tradition
that goes back to the cradle of
civilization they're built of bundled
reeds woven into columns and bent into
giant arches hand woven mats formed the
roof they're comfortable inside even in
the summer heat in the early 1990s
Saddam Hussein tore down most of the
motifs the culture of the Marsh Arabs
was almost destroyed the Iraqi dictator
had most of the nearby swamps drained
for military purposes
everything was bare and empty we didn't
even have water to drink people killed
each other over a single canister of
water these images testify to the extent
of the destruction some 15,000 square
kilometers of marshes were transformed
by Saddam Hussein into a desert
wasteland after the Gulf War ended in
1991 the Iraqi dictator was determined
to prevent local Shiite rebels from
taking shelter or going underground here
Iraqi born Azam Al wash is a hydraulic
engineer he spent 25 years in exile in
the United States after the fall of
Saddam Hussein in 2003 he decided to
return to his homeland you're all - - a
bridge that you remember when you were
young and you remember going on top of
the Britain and seeing the forest of
reeds the life the birds in the distance
and you go to that same point
and he see nothing but dust desiccated
earth tumbleweed death in late 2003
outwash was able to flood about
one-third of the drained marshland the
water was released from four areas in
the dams that had been built by Saddam
Hussein it was a cloak-and-dagger
operation done together with ecologist
jassim al Assad II you could see the
seedlings the tips of free it's growing
clean is coming coming back and voila
two months later the water is clear the
rains are up and life is back turns out
all we need to do restore to restore
nature is to let her work by herself
dawn is still hours away we take a boat
out into the marshes the city of Dubai
ish Iraq was once known as the Venice of
the Middle East in the mid-1990s
hundreds of thousands of people fled the
region hoping to escape the brutal Iraqi
dictatorship but now that the marshland
is fertile again more and more people
are returning it's a success story one
of the few today in a country devastated
by war
water and reeds as far as the eye can
see 300 species of birds can be found
here two-thirds of the species native to
Iraq
water buffalo swim past the boat and
graze on the reeds largely undisturbed
by their owners 50 species of fish swim
in the waters several thousand families
now make a living from fishing almost
like back in the good old days this
morning the catch is scant normally
though Abu Haidar earns about $60 a day
from his catch that's considered a good
living in Iraq where unemployment is
high many fishermen spend several nights
on one of the small islands until they
have a catch of about a hundred kilos
then the long journey to the market is
worthwhile
a lot of done.we Marsh Arabs don't need
much but there's one thing we always
need water we're like fish without water
we're dead we pray to God that it won't
just be 2 meters high but 3 metrand and
then good yeah Allah and it doesn't talk
it's a hard life it was always hard to
be a fisherman but thank God today we
can fish again under sodom fishing gear
was banned for years even though it's
very hard work and we're exhausted at
the end of the day we can push again
better than before this is how bread is
made here in the marshland they make the
dough the day before and let it rise
overnight
now it's time to bake the bread using an
improvised Bunsen burner made out of
burning reeds the flatbread has a
slightly smoky flavor but it's filling
for the locals the marshes give them
everything they need at the midday break
the researchers return to their
headquarters meanwhile Abu Haidar helps
his wife who was cutting reeds nearby
for locals it's part of their daily
routine the tradition makes it possible
to survive in the marshland the reeds
are the stuff of life providing
everything from animal feed to
construction material to insulation even
flour for bread
we return to Jew beige the boat is
sometimes steered using one foot while
standing but that takes skill
Ljuba ich is a city with a turbulent
history until 1993 it had a hundred
thousand residents after saddam hussein
drained the marshes only six hundred
people remained now more than 50
thousand live here again in humble
surroundings
among them Sawa and her husband Abu
Haidar they have ten children seven
girls and three boys the family was also
forced to flee in 1993 and spent ten
years living in the Iraqi capital
Baghdad it's a time they would rather
forget
Abu Haider tends to his only remaining
cow back when his oldest son married he
slaughtered one of them seven went to
the dowry for his daughter-in-law
it was almost everything the family
possessed there's one bedroom for the
entire family
Abu Haidar shows us how they live the
blankets are laid out on the floor he
has only one jalabiya for special
occasions but they make do and are happy
with it even when the day's meal is a
plain one
Salwa serves rice and beans as a main
dish today and most days
we head out to one of the seven meter
high dams in the 1990s Saddam Hussein
used these dams to drain the marshes the
area extends over five hundred twenty
kilometers every digger every truck and
every heavy earth mover in the entire
country ended up here for two years
nearly all of Iraq's economic output was
moved to the south to divert the Tigris
and Euphrates rivers azam awash and just
some acedia are planning more
environmental projects a wash has even
founded a university in northern Iraq
but for both men their heart is in the
marshes they used simple methods to undo
much of the damage wrought by Saddam
Hussein and they take pride in that
accomplishment in December 1993 at this
very spot they used a digger to make the
first hole in the dam the water started
flowing back to where it belonged
we return to the boats to take our last
ride on the water
the hour is right before dusk are
especially beautiful
the marshes are our what I come to
regain my sanity you know one hour in in
this wonder world and I'm peaceful I'm I
don't have anxiety tomorrow will take
care of itself
I see the birds and it's fantastic I see
the fishermen fishing and making a
living and it's a fantastic thing I see
trash and I say it's the cradle of
civilization the biblical book of
Genesis refers to the Garden of Eden and
two of the mighty rivers that flowed
from it were the Tigris and the
Euphrates
and as the day draws to a close it seems
this could well be the original Eden a
marshland in southern Iraq now a
paradise restored